[Musique]
bonjour à tous bonjour à toutes
bienvenue sur passé sauvage on sait
depuis longtemps que les humains de la
préhistoire n'hésitent pas à s'aventurer
dans les massifs de montagne on a par
exemple documenté sur cette chaîne un
site comme la grande Rivoire dans le
massif du verre corp abri sous roche
fréquenté par les chasseurs cuueilleurs
depuis plus de 10000 ans puis par les
éleveurs néolithiques qui montaient avec
leurs bêtes dans les alpages de depuis
10000 ans le climat est en effet assez
proche de ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
la grande glaciation est terminée et ces
reliefs alpins avec leur vallée
couvertees de forêts et leur prairies
d'altitude sont alors largement
accessibles pour les humains de nombreux
sites datés de la préhistoire récente
sont d'ailleurs fouillés depuis des
décennies dans tout l'arcalpin en
revanche quand on aborde les périodes
plus anciennes du Paléolithique les
sites se font très rare à l'époque la
planète était encore plongée dans une
période glaciaire et les humains
devaient probable ement rchigner un peu
plus à s'aventurer à l'intérieur des
massifs c'est sans doute pour cette
raison qu'on connaît très peu de
vestiges antérieurs à 10000 ans au cœur
des Alpes pourtant on sait de sources
sûres que les humains du Paléolitique
n'hésitaient pas à parcourir les vallées
et emprunter l'école on le sait grâce à
des témoignages indirects depuis
longtemps les sites préhistoriques du
littoral ont en effet révélé des objets
façonnés avec du silex originaire de
l'intérieur des massifs l'étude
minutieuse des outils a parfois permis
de retrouver les endroits précis d'où
proviennent les blocs de silex loin à
l'intérieur des Alpes et comme le silex
ne se déplace pas tout seul en étudiant
sa signature géologique bah on peut
remonter jusqu'au Vallé où se sont
approvisionnés les humains suivre la
trace du silex jusqu'au cœur des Alpes
et finalement une très bonne manière de
trouver des sites datés du Paléolithique
c'est cette logique qu'on suivi les
archéologues du laboratoire spam du CNRS
et de l'université Côte d'Azur et du
lampa de l'université d'ex-marseille
leur travail de prospection mené à
partir de 2000 2009 sous la direction
d'Antonin Tomaso et Guillaume poraz a
permis de resserrer les recherches sur
une vallée en particulier et d'y mettre
au jour plusieurs site préhistorique
dont un exceptionnel gisement du
Paléolithique supérieur cette vallée
située au nord du Var c'est celle du
Jabron un affluent du Verdon et de son
impressionnant canyon elle débute elle
aussi par des gorges qui entaillent
profondément les couches sédimentaires
du Crétacé et du Jurassique mais se
développe ensuite en une plaine
alluviale large de plusieurs kilomètres
est particulièrement propice aux
occupations humaines au cours de cette
vidéo je vais m'entretenir avec Louise
purdu géoarchéologue et géomorphologue
ne vous inquiétez pas elle va vous
expliquer ce que c'est que ce métier
elle est chargée de recherche au spam et
elle participe à ce programme de
recherche depuis son origine donc moi je
suis géoarchéologue et géomorphologue
donc les géomorphologues lui il
travaillent plutôt sur le l'histoire des
reliefs qui nous entourent et un peu
comment il se mettent en place et ils
évoluent au cours du temps le
géoarchéologue lui il intègre plutôt une
dimension humaine à ces questionnementsl
donc il cherche à comprendre comment
l'homme s'est implanté dans son
environnement comment il a transformé et
exploité son environnement et pourquoi
et comment il l'a abandonné et donc on
travaille de bah en collaboration avec
les archéologues ou les préhistoriens
qui eux ont besoin de comprendre un peu
mieux cet environnement mais aussi
d'autres spécialistes comme les
paléoécologues écologues pour mieux
reconstituer toute l'histoire de de
l'environnement qui entoure les
occupations humaines au départ c'est
quoi c'est que vous avez des vous
trouvez des silex
sur le littoral qui n'ont rien à faire
ici vous AZ tout compris on trouve des
silexes sur le littoral qui n'ont rien à
faire ici c'est-à-dire queil y a pas de
silex il y a pas de ressources
silissuses au bord de la mer et donc
pour comprendre d'où venait ce matériel
il y a des prospections archéologiques
et géologiques qui ont été mise en place
à partir de 2009 notamment dans le nord
du varard où il y a beaucoup de
ressources silicieuses mais c'est un
territoire un peu particulier parce que
c'est un territoire qui est très
encaissé et en canyon où on a rarement
découvert des sites archéologiques et
dans le cadre de ces prospections où on
a découvert toutes ces ressources
silisseuses on a aussi découvert le
potentiel de petites zones qui sont très
localisées qu'on a trouvé grâce à des
cartes qui sont des petites vallées et
ces petites vallées en fait sont des
lieux vraiment idéaux pour tout ce qui
va être circulation des hommes dans les
montagne mais aussi piège à sédiment et
piège à sédiment ça veut dire piège àite
archéologique dès lors une équipe
internationale de chercheurs et
d'étudiants découvre et fouille
plusieurs sites préhistoriques de la
vallée qui datent d'époque distinctes le
plus ancien et sans doute le plus
surprenant est un site de plein air daté
du Paléolithique supérieur au lieu d'î
les près de l'or les archéologues ont
mis au jour des vestiges d'un campement
au bord de l'ancienit de la rivière
l'endroit a vraisemblablement servi à
découper des carcasses de chevaux pour
les manger et faire sécher les peaux
tout autour ont été retrouvés de très
nombreux déchets de taille de silex et
quelques outils caractéristiques comme
des petites pointes et des lamelles à
dos ces outils ont permis d'attribuer le
site à l'époque du gravéien final ou de
l'épigravéien soit il y a environ 25000
ans c'est un S léolitique supérieure
donc on a une occupation grosso modo
entre on va dire 22000 et 28000 avant
aujourd'hui on est dans une
période qu'on appelle l'épigravécien
mais c'est le plein maximum glaciaire ce
plein maximum glaciaire il atteint son
pic entre 21000 et 23000 donc on est
dans une période hyper froide il y a pas
de glaciers les glaciers grosso modo au
sud des Alpes s'arrête 100 km au nord
d'accord de là où on se situe donc nous
on est dans des conditions qui sont
périglacières donc c'est pas des
conditions qui sont idéales mais en tout
cas on n'est pas sur des glaciers ce qui
permet aux gens de venir de circuler
faut imaginer du vent du Mistral des un
paysage avec beaucoup de pain peut-être
un peu
stépique mais en tout cas avec des
ressources et ce matériel ce ce ce silex
qui est indispensable à cette époque là
en tout cas comment justement un site
qui est donc proche de l'eau se conserve
comment est-ce que c'est un avantage
est-ce que c'est un inconvénient les prè
de l'or il est sur ce qu'on appelle une
terrasse à lu c'est-à-dire une
succession de dépôt de cru qui se met en
place entre on va dire 30000 avant
aujourd'hui jusqu'à 22000 avant
aujourd'hui et on a une succession
d'environ 3 m de dépôt très fins sont
des des limons donc c'est comme de la
farine ces despôts très fins ils ont
enterré tout un tas de niveau
archéologiques dans lequel le matériel n
n'a pas bougé il est vraiment sur place
extrêmement bien préservé et il couvre
voilà on va dire 5 6000 ans faut
imaginer une rivière qui est environ
peut-être 300 400 m du site avec des
gens qui qui qui s'installent dans ce
qu'on appelle une plaine distale un peu
loin du cours d'eau protéger des cru
tout en étant plus ou moins à côté de
des ressources mais par contre sur les
50000 dernières années ça a pas toujours
été comme ça et donc on appelle ça une
sorte de préservation en lambau on a des
petits bouts de différentes périodes
qu'on retrouve entre laamont et la valle
de cette petite vallée les près de l'or
par exemple on a une des limitations en
terme de mètes carré on sait la taille
que fait le site il est il est assez
grand tout en étant pas très grand on
voit exactement à quel moment il s'est
fait éroder par des dépôts de cru à quel
moment il s'est fait éroder par des des
dépôts qui viennent des PES au-delà de
la fouille des sites ce programme a donc
pour objectif de retracer toute
l'évolution de la vallée du Jabron et
des différents changements du climat qui
ont façonné le paysage transformé la
végétation et permis l'installation des
groupes humains qui parcourent la région
à la fin de la glaciation à partir d'il
y a 13500 ans des groupes de chasseurs
cuilleurs fréquentent un abri sousroche
situé juste au-dessus de la plaine la
Baume de montivert cette petite caverne
avec son Porsche de 10 m de large et de
5 m de profondeur exposé au sud-est
offre en effet un abri assez confortable
pour faire une halte sondé en 2017 il a
livré essentiellement des silex taillés
et dans les strat supérieure plus
récente daté du 7e millénaire avant
Jésus-Christ des ossements d'animaux
presque 2000 fragments de coque de
noisette et même des coquillage marin
perforés et des traces de colorants qui
témoignent de la confection de parure la
Baume de montivvert a aussi fourni de
nombreux charbons de bois ce sont en
grande majorité des charbons de pain
mais il y a aussi un peu de chaîne de
Buie et un charbons d'érable en plus de
documenter les essences de bois choisies
par les humains pour faire leur feux ces
charbons ont fait l'objet d'analyse
isotopique alors si vous avez vu une des
dernières vidéos vous savez qu'on a déjà
parlé de ça sur la chaîne au sujet des
dents et en fait le principe est
exactement le même avec le charbon
seulement là ce qu'on cherche c'est pas
les isotopes de strontium mais ceux du
carbone dans le cas de la Baume de
montiver les archéologues ont cherché
les isotopes de carbone 13 contrairement
au carbone 14 le carbone 13 est un
isotope stable et qui ne se désintègre
pas il peut donc pas servir à dater en
revanche il fournit une bonne indication
de la température qui régnait au moment
où la plante était vivante donc en
analysant les charbons de pin des
différentes strates du site l'équipe de
Benjamin odiar est parvenu à montrer
l'évolution relative des températures
sur la période d'occupation et il
apparaît clairement un épisode chaud et
sec aux alentours de 7300 avant
Jésus-Christ il y a un véritable
changement des paysages au cours de
cette période donc on quitte le dernier
maximum glaciaire qu'on avait auprès de
l'or pour rentrer dans une nouvelle
phase qu'on appelle le Tardi glaciaire
ce Tardi glaciaire on va dire qu'il
commença environ 18000 ans à peu près il
est associé à un réchauffement
climatique même s'il y a quelques
épisodes de froid et donc ça ça implique
plusieurs choses ça implique notamment
plus d'eau euh plus d'eau ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir plus d'érosions sur les
pantes et va y avoir de l'eau qui va
couler au fond du cours d'eau cette eau
qui va couler au fond du cours d'eau
elle va commencer à le creuser et on
assiste à une phase ce qu'on appelle
d'incision ça c'est ce qui se passe
vraiment entre le fin du dernier maximum
glaciaire et le début du Tardi glaciaire
les cours d'eau commencent à creuser et
un peu partout dans le sud-est de la
France on voit beaucoup d'érosions sur
les pin c'estàdire que ça a découvert
une végétation un peu claircemée et donc
ça érode ça érode ça érode ça remplit le
le le la vallée de plein de sédiments et
en fait ça la ça la bouche ça c'est
important cette petite vallée va se
boucher euh à l'entrée des gorges en
avat ce bouchon va générer deux choses
la première c'est que ça va créer un
palé au lac dans la vallée ce palé au
lac qui va se mettre en place à partir
du début du Tardi glaciè on va dire
autour de il y a 18000 ans en parallèle
on assiste une fois que ce lac est mis
en place en aval à donc de l'érosion sur
les portes les occupations humaines on
les trouve principalement dans les abris
au-dessus et notamment la bomme de
montiver qui occupa entre 10000 et 8000
avant au jour par et ce qui passe à ce
moment-là c'est que on observe
effectivement de l'érosion dans cet abri
et qu'on identifie de façon plus précise
en terme de T grâce à une technique qui
est l'isotopie sur les charbons de bois
et ce réchauffement se
poursuit progressivement par contre ce
qu'on voit notamment à la Baume de
montivert c'est que ce petit changement
il change pas les pratiques humaines
voilà il change pas les pratiques de
subsistance il change pas les
comportements techniques il change pas
les comportements symboliques on voit
une continuité dans cette occupation qui
est indép pendante du changement
environnemental qui va avec cette
période tardie glaciaire plus tard au
Néolithique les humains occupent à
nouveau le fond de la vallée un site
daté du Néolithique moyen et appartenant
à la culture chasséenne a été identifié
au lieu dit Le Moulin Neuf environ 1,m5
en naal du site paléoliique en explorant
les berges de la rivière les
archéologues ont repéré quelques
fragments de silex taillés dans une
coupe naturelle de quelques mètres de
haut la fouille a ensuite révélé une
stratigraphie complexe fait là encore de
différents niveaux de sédiments déposés
pendant les épisodes de cru dans la
partie basse un niveau archéologique a
livré plus de 200 fragments de silex
taillés et quatre tessons de céramique
très altérés grâce à la présence de
microcharbon peut-être les vestige de
défrichement par le feu une datation a
été réalisée et situe l'occupation entre
4000 et 3800 avant juschr ce qui est
particulièrement intéressant dans ce
cas-là c'est que l'occupation de ce site
est contemporaine de la disparition d'un
lac tout proche au lieu dit les
Condamines c'est le lac de Trigance
d'accord lac de Trigance et donc ce lac
il a disparu il a disparu tout à fait il
disparaît au moment on va dire autour de
6000 avant notre ère à peu près hein on
est au Néolithique ce qui se passe au
néolithtique c'est qu'on est toujours
dans cette phase de réchauffement
climatique on est sorti du Tardi
glaciaire on arrive à l'olocè et cette
période est caractérisée notamment par
une par des pluies qui sont beaucoup
plus régulières qu'avant et un un climat
qui ressemble beaucoup plus à l'actuel
et ça ça aussi ça va avoir des
conséquences assez importantes sur le
paysage parce que des pluies plus
régulières vont complètement transformer
le fonctionnement des cours d'eau donc
on avait des petits torents là ces
petits torents ils érodaient sur les
pentes ils remplissaient la vallée de
sédiment puis on avait ce lac qui était
bouché faut imaginer des pluie plus
régulière c'est plus plus régulière vont
faire sauter le bouchon du lac le cours
d'eau va commencer à couler et ce petit
Jabron va arriver à se reconnecter avec
le Verdon et faire ce qu'on appelle un
hydrosystème comme celui qu'on a
aujourd'hui la conséquence directe c'est
ce cours d'eau qui va suivre un rythme
plus régulier et plus stable va avoir
une fréquence de crue moins importante
moins cru ça veut dire que les plaines
qui sont à côté du cour d'au vont se
stabiliser la végétation va pouvoir
pousser il va pas y avoir de dépôt de
cru ni d'érosion et ces environnements
là sont complètement propices aux
occupations humaines c'est l'idéal en
fait qu'on cherche vraiment à
s'installer dans une plaine qui nous
paraît euh on va dire plutôt stable et
dans quel pas de risque de d'intempérie
ou de cru régulière et on va dire entre
8000 et 5500 avant aujourd'hui on a dans
la vallée du jabon comme à l'échelle
régionale cette stabilité des paysages
qui est propice aux implantations et aux
occupation néolitique dans la région
alors ça se
voit sur le site notamment du Moulin
Neuf qui a étéoué dans dans la vallée
qui a été découvert dans le cadre de
prospection archéologique et
géomorphologique on a trouvé du matériel
dans un magnifique palais sol donc un
paléosol on peut reconnaître sur le
terrain il est il est brun il est riche
en matière organique il se casse en
petits morceaux comme de la terre de de
jardin actuel hein voilà c'est vraiment
ça et ce qu'on a trouvé ils sont un peu
brûlés donc faut imaginer les premières
traces de bah on essaie d'éclaircir la
végétation on essaie d'ouvrir le le
paysage principalement pour du du tout
ce qui va être pastoral hein donc on a
pas d'agriculture à ce moment-là encore
dans dans le sud-est de la France un
paysage stable ça invite à à l'investir
de façon un peu plus perine ça ça
exactementc c'est exactement ça et nous
on le voit vraiment c'est ce qu'on
cherche c'est la priorité ce qu'on
appelle sépalé au sol donc c'est pas des
sols occupés comme ce ce que les
archéologues pourraient imaginer c'est
vraiment de la terre qui est brune qui
se casse en petits morceaux et qui
indique que il y avait une mise en
surface de la végétation de la pluie des
insectes des fourmis ça a tout
homogénéisé dans le sol et ça veut dire
qu'on a un paysage qui est stable égal
occupation humaine c'est vraiment ça
c'est vraiment ça qu'on cherche l'étude
réalisé à l'échelle de la vallée permet
de retracer plusieurs dizaines de
millénaires de transformation de paysage
et de mieux comprendre les stratégies
d'occupation du territoire par les
humains de la préhistoire grâce à cet
effort collectif pluridisciplinaire
soutenu sur plus d'une décennie et
valorisé par son intégration dans le
Parc Naturel du Verdon la vallée du
Jabron est incontestablement devenu un
lieu de référence pour la connaissance
de la préhistoire alpine donc l'idée
c'est de continuer ce travail
géoarchéologique à l'échelle de la
vallée sortir de cette vallée passer au
bassin versant du Verdon idéalement à
connecter avec la dururance et ensuite
au rô hein donc on travaille vraiment à
une très grande échelle et corréler ça
un peu avec tout un tas de projets de
fouille euh qui commencent à se mettre
en place le le long du Verdon c'est fou
parce que dans cette vallée vous arrivez
à
à toute la toute la chrono euh on a
toute la chrono c'est super mais mais
cette chronologie là on on l'a parce
qu'on a une approche qui est vraiment
pas celle que du site mais qui est
vraiment celle de la vallée et donc on
on cherche pas juste à comprendre une
occupation on cherche à comprendre tout
l'espace et comment tous l'espace a
évolué et comment il a été propice aux
occupations humaines ou au contraire
comment il les a potentiellement érodé
ou ou ou supprimer et voilà c'est la fin
de notre vidéo merci à Louis purdu
d'avoir répondu à mes questions cette
vidéo a été réalisée à la demande
d'écoscience sud-provence Alpe Côte
d'Azur et propulsée par ple azur si vous
voulez que creuser le sujet et ben il y
a une autre vidéo qui vous attend sur la
chaîne d'écoscience c'est un entretien
que j'ai fait avec Louise purdu et son
collègue Guillaume poraz le lien il est
juste ici dans le petit i également en
barre d'info j'espère que ça vous plaira
dans tous les cas je vous remercie
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je vous
souhaite de très belles fêtes de fin
d'année on se retrouve et ben en janvier
à bientôt
salut
[Musique]